Shanghai is a mega city of over 26
million people and China's most
important industrial center so it's no
wonder that it hosts one of the world's
biggest car shows every two years
alternating with the auto China show and
Beijing the world's car makers show
their models here it's also a must for
increasingly popular Chinese car makers
but that hasn't discouraged
international manufacturers Volkswagen
through a huge party on the eve of the
show's opening piano virtuoso Liang
Liang and world-class acrobats were on
hand to help launch the concept
crossblue coupe a the car puts out 305
kilowatts of power on just three liters
of fuel per 100 kilometers thanks to a
plug-in hybrid system that drives the
car 33 kilometers on electric power
alone Pelican instrum bought a VW CEO
Martin Winterkorn says that china is one
of the company's most important markets
growth in the first quarter was up
twenty one percent he says Volkswagen
sold 2.8 million cars here last year but
look set to break the 3 million mark
this year I'm young offensive swinging
Mercedes is also a major presence at the
show it's trumpeting both innovative
models and well established cars
Shanghai was the world premiere for the
GLA concept car introduced with the
slogan escaped the everyday the new
compact crossover SUV has an innovative
all-wheel-drive 4motion concept for
superior handling and maximum traction
on and off road the GLA should help
mercedes win new customers following the
success of the relaunched a class forty
percent of that cars buyers were
first-timers sadies customers
the new Audi a3 sedans length grows to
nearly 4 meters 50 thanks in part to its
2.64 meter wheelbase the sedan version
of the a3 is wider than the sportback
model and built lower to the ground that
should also please chinese customers who
prefer larger cars second is among the
Chinese car market will soon be the
largest in the world explains Audi CEO
and will remain so for years to come he
expects car sales to rise to 20 million
a year in the long term Audi has been in
China for 25 years now and wants to
remain the number one luxury marque
notes you've always seemed to pay me
amake no mines does one off like see ott
is also eager to get a piece of that
growing pie last year the spanish car
maker made its debut with the auto china
car show in beijing and is now gradually
expanding its network of dealers in the
country as it isn't so yeah its R&D
executive explains that its main focus
currently is on Europe where the lyon
and other new models are proving very
popular but the company wants to see
growth beyond Europe and China is
crucial see Ott's latest baby is on show
here in Shanghai the Leon SC sports
coupe a
BMW is an established player in China
and even has its own factories there the
highlight of its stand and Shanghai is
the x4 concept car a shrunken version of
the x6 the study gives an idea of what
awaits customers on its launch in the
summer of 2014 the technical
similarities of the x3 are unmistakable
aside from the 5 centimeter drop in
height the two cars have the same
dimensions it's on the design front
where the biggest differences are
evident
now the family of X products is in high
demand here as well so x1 is now
produced locally but products like the
x5 like the x6 like the x3 and of course
the new addition to the family the x4
these will have a great footing here as
well and Porsche is also in town of
course four years ago Shanghai saw the
world premiere of the Panamera and now
the sports car specialists are
introducing the new generation of the
luxury sedan there's also an extended
length executive version boasting extra
leg room and space galore for rear-seat
passengers
poor should tops off its presence here
with the S e-hybrid the first plug-in
hybrid drive in the luxury segment the
new model claims an all-electric driving
range of 36 kilometers
you